good afternoon everybody and welcome to
uh this week's meeting of the planning
and development management committee
uh just to introduce myself my name is
adam williams i'm the vice chair of the
committee
uh we're not being joined by councillor
walsh who is the committee chair
this evening and the start of the
meeting i just like to read out some
broadcast information so that we're
clear
um for your information this meeting has
been live streamed and recorded
so please mute your microphones to
minimize background noise
if you wish to speak on an item please
use the chat facility to notify myself
and then wait until i invite you to
speak before making your comments please
state your name
so attendees at this committee are the
elected members who make up
the planning and development management
committee but we are also joined by
council offices from our planning
department our highways unit
our legal department and democratic
services
and just before we turn to the
applications
for consideration this evening and just
like to confirm attendances as i
understand it we have
uh apologies received from councillor
walsh who has been substituted by
councillor thomas
apology from council accordingly an
apology from councillor hartley who has
been substituted by councillor
canola an apology from councillor jerome
who's been substituted by
councillor welton and an apology from
council and minister has been
substituted by
council the new gloss and for those
members who are substituting thank you
for doing so including a short notice i
think some of you
um minutes of the last
meeting have been circulated is there a
member's happy to pass them as a true
inaccurate record
any concerns i should agree i'm sure
wonderful um are there any members
looking to
issue a declaration of interest
um just moving on
as i understand it there haven't been
any questions from members of the public
can we just confirm that
um member from the democratic services
team
thank you um the additional information
report has already been circulated via
email
and we'll now turn to applications to
develop the first application for
consideration this evening is
one double zero trouble six multi-story
car park
fourth floor stretford shopping mall and
that's on page 15
of your agenda pack there is a speaker
wishing to speak to the application but
before we hear from them
the item is going to be introduced by ms
milner from the planning department
thank you councillor williams i'm just
going to share my screen reviews
presentation
right i trust you will see that
i'll say that as yes the application
before you
relates to the four-story um open top
car park at stratford mall situated in
the designated
town center um
this is just an aerial view of the car
park as you can see here
and just a street view and there is the
top deck
the application proposes a temporary
two-year consent
for a drinking establishment and cinema
their proposed use um would allow for a
six month um each year opening
with a cinema use with the cinema use
operating once a month
and for a weekend which we are assuming
as a friday to sunday
the application is reported to planning
committee because the council do have an
interest in the land
the key issues are the principle of the
uses posed
the design impact the impact of the
youth on the amenity of adjacent
residential properties
and parking the proposed use is
considered to be wholly appropriate
in the town center and the design
impacts
from the temporary bar and from the
cinema screen are considered to be very
limited and acceptable
the proposed management and operation of
the use
is considered to be acceptable and
mitigate
and any impacts that would be
detrimental to amenity
of surrounding residents and the
loss of the the car parking in the short
term is considered acceptable and our
high res officers have raised no
objection and is considered that
the highly sustainable location and with
the metro link close by
but also that there is submission
parking elsewhere on the site
therefore subject to the conditions
outlined in your report
we do recommend approval thank you
thank you mr milner um just before we
hear from the speaker i did mean at the
start of this application to declare
that the
applicant is known to me um i
live in stratford and i have um
frequented
uh her older um
units that she owns as a two units so i
don't consider that to be a prejudicial
interest as well we'll be staying
on the application now i understand that
we will hear from
ms garlic is ms garlic on the call
yes okay um
you'll have three minutes to speak miss
garlic
and if you do one over we'll just uh
politely ask you
to wrap up
i think at the moment you're still muted
is that better yeah yep that's working
well um hello everyone as um some of you
will know
it's been quite a long road to get here
so it's very nice to be finally speaking
to you all
um the up top is a project which has
brought together a range of
local residents with a passion for music
culture food drink
horticulture and possibly the unsaid and
what we'd like to do is um put a six
month
insta installation on the top floor of
stratford's multi-story car park
um that's currently completely unused
it's not been used for about
three years and so it's kind of
unutilized space in the town centre
um we'd like to use it to complain of
all of our passions and create a garden
area
on the top floor which would have a bar
um
temporary food installations and then
the monthly cinema events
and we don't plan to put on amplified
music
because we wouldn't like to annoy local
residents um but we will have
um acoustic music installations on
certain days of the week
um we propose we we're very aware that
um you guys will be very concerned first
of all about the health and safety of
our guests
and um secondly about us not um
annoying our local residents which it's
really important for us as well
and so we've tried very hard to put
together a management plan which
because we don't quite have the budget
to be able to to do
um some of the full assessments works on
a sort of softly softly approach
so um it's very careful we don't let
people
um near the edge we have a very big
buffer zone so that nobody can fall off
and we don't have amplified music and we
only have sort of intermittent cinema
events so
we hope that by sort of being very
careful we've mitigated some of the
problems which
might come up um
[Music]
i think what we'd like to do is let
welcome local residents
up to the top floor to bring people
together to create a sense of community
but i think more than that we want to
create um a destination
where people from all over the north
west will come to enjoy um
cinema or enjoy the garden space or
enjoy something that's completely
different to what's
currently on offer um and i think that's
really important because i grew up in
stratford and i know that some people
see stratford as just a route
with like a weird blue building on the
way into town
and i think what we'd like to do as
local residents who are like really
passionate about stratford and really
love our town we want to create that
feeling for lots of other people as well
bring people in from all over the
northwest and create a
and i think that's my three minutes uh
say thank you very much
thank you ms garlic are there any
members looking to open the discussion
on this
um nobody's indicating that as yet but i
mean i i'll just make a few remarks i
won't speak at length on this
application
um personally i think that this you know
is an attractive
application i think it enhances the town
center
offer for recreational use i think it's
an ideal sort of facility in light of
um the restrictions we now find imposed
um
by the copper 19 novel corona virus
my principal concern have been as the
applicant spoke to about
potential impacts on um residents in the
neighborhood in the immediate locality
but
uh i i was reassured that we haven't had
any concerns raised by the
council's um environmental health team
in respective
noise or the impact of noise and i was
further reinsured
reassured really by the fact that you
know no local residents have put in
any representations objects in the
application so
i'm really quite happy for this
application to be approved tonight and
as i say
i hope that it is um something that can
enhance the
leisure offer in stratford now
um yep i can see the council of procter
has indicated
yeah uh thank you chair yes i'm also
very um
a positive view towards this application
um i think it's very innovative
innovative
and uh it's it's a very interesting idea
um i think it will help
with the regeneration of stratford and
help to promote a bit of a
nighttime economy which is still quite
badly lacking at the moment
um and also in
these times you know create quite a few
jobs as well which is
is it's quite an important factor as
well
um and as as as you said yourself said
this is a news facility so it's actually
bringing something back
that's not used at all so it's gonna
be you you use part of the the land
that's that's not
utilized at the moment i too did have
the concerns about
some of the impacts on residents
particularly in terms of
the light intrusion because to the
nearby properties
and the noise impact as well
but looking through the reports i think
the officers have looked into this and
they're satisfied with that would be no
significant impact on
on residents so i'm happy to go along
with that in in
both those respects although as i say i
did have some
initial concerns and properties
there's a lot of residential properties
very close to this but i think
it should be okay i think the officers
have addressed this in the report
um obviously there's going to be the
monitoring that goes along with this
this application of it provision goes
ahead so
you know there will be obviously some
potential sanction if
uh if the the conditions aren't uh
complied with the final point is that
obviously
this is a little bit more safer than
other types of parts it's kind of
in the open air to a degree so it's much
safer in these times of
learning about social distance and the
impact of the coronavirus
i think this is slightly safer than that
so that's the positive aspect of it
so overall i had some concerns but
um very positive and i'll be voting for
it thank you chair
thank you councillor councilman stanley
uh thank you chair well to save some
time what you said just to
agree with everything the council
proctors you said that's exactly what i
was going to say
apart from when i s i have no
reservations about it whatsoever things
an innovative use currently a very dead
space
um and if nobody else has proposed this
i'm happy to i'm happy to propose it
thank you councillor winston the uh
councillor morgan
thank you chair um again i'm not going
to really speak um
at length because i'm going to agree
with both two previous uh two speakers
against someone stanley and cancer proxy
i think it's really positive development
um really um
surprised in some ways and um i'm
pleased there's been no objections so
i'm happy to second this um that we
agree with officer recommendations
supportless thank you
thank you councillor morgan that the
application has now been proposed and
seconded are there any of the members
looking to speak before we move to a
vote
yes i did raise my hands sorry counselor
rigby
yes thank you very much indeed um i
appreciate them
with scarlett's um enthusiasm and
officer's report i'm not going to
vote against the the um
application because it does have
potential
but having read the report i'm not
really convinced that the cinema
on the car park and bar will do anything
to maintain the vibrant shopping center
i hope i'm wrong i'm not a resident of
stratford i used to be
i used to live 200 yards from the center
and i go back as far as
the sun's nightclub but that's really
showing my age
um but um i'm not really convinced
but i just hope it's successful and that
young
people will appreciate it thank you
thank you councillor rigby um i suggest
if we move to a vote unless there's
anyone
burning desire to make further comment
it doesn't look like it what i'll do
i'll just run through
um members as they appear on my screen
and i'll ask you to confirm whether or
not you're
in favor or opposed to the application
to counselor proctor in favor
okay councillor kerry
in favour chairman thank you councillor
councillor rick b
in favor trevor thank you councillor
councillor morgan
in favour chair thank you councillor new
gosh
favorite chair thank you councillor
councillor welton
i'm not receiving any audio there
counselor wilson sorry
sorry oh can you hear me now
yeah that's million yeah yes uh in favor
and old people watch films too so it's
good
and keep going for the counselor thomas
in favor chair shout out thank you
councillor councillor stanley
uh thank you chad your favorite
recommendation thank you
councillor dr barkley
thank you vice chair i support the
officer's recommendation to grant
thank you counselor stunning
i think you might still be on mute and
there we go thank you councillor and
councillor
in favor thank you councillor um i will
also
vote to approve this application so um i
make that the application has been
approved
unanimously okay um
the next application that we will turn
to is
one double zero 105. five knows the
avenue which is on page one of your
report
and before we move to the discussion uh
the application is going to be
introduced by mr pearson
and i'll just uh share my screen with
you now
can everybody see that
assume that you can um okay this
application
is being reported to the planning and
development management committee
because an officer of the council could
be deemed to have an interest in the
site
the application property comprises a
two-story terraced house with an
original
two-story outrigger an elongated rear
garden dissected by
a gunner
the proposal is the erection of a single
story rear extensions that would extend
both to the side into the rear
of the original outrigger and for the
erection of a rear door
key considerations relate to design
appearance
residential immunity impact upon
neighboring properties
no objection been received to the
proposal
the proposal was been amended in scale
to reduce the projection
the rear extension at the side of the
outrigger
to 2.7 meters along the shared boundary
with number seven
in order to comply with spd4
so therefore considered that the
proposed extensions would not have any
unacceptable impacts on the efficiency
of many
properties whilst the proposed dormer
is relatively large and would have a
flat roof
it would retain a significant gap to the
eaves and be set down slightly from the
rich
dormer could be constructed under
committed development rates
and having regard to this fallback
position it's considered that this
element
is acceptable in design terms therefore
consider that proposed extensions and
alterations would not detract from the
character and visual appearance of the
area
development's considered to be an
according to cl7 of the court strategy
guns in the epf and is therefore
recommended for approval
thank you thank you mr pearson
i don't think there are any speakers to
this application so
consequently we just move straight to
the discussion
um are there any members looking to open
the discussion
now
all right councillor thomas
thank you chad yeah from the report and
as you look through the paperwork you
can see they've made
amendments to fitting with the
requirements and
i don't see any uh
problems with the proposal and i'm happy
to propose
well thank you councillor thomas
councillor procter
thank you chair yeah fairly
straightforward uh
application um reasonable plans
particularly in terms of the
changes that have been made um there'd
be no representations from neighbours
which is always a good sign
um so i don't think there's any of any
particular impact on visual immunity
uh the street scene no loss of light um
i don't think it's going to be
overlooked either so i'm happy to
approve it thank you chair
thank you uh councillor procter any
other members
wishing to make any observations
it doesn't look like it i mean i will
just say that i had a
look on um the some of the neighboring
properties on nosey avenue and it did
look to me as though
um some of those have had similar sorts
of extensions so i found that quite
reassuring really and similarly to
what council of proctors said you know
the fact that there haven't been any
representations
um and then also as mr pearson had
highlighted a huge chunk of it would
have been permitted development
um anyway so really i don't feel like i
have any concerns there i mean the
application has now been proposed by
councillor thomas
natural council that puts a you second
the application
uh i didn't but i can do happy too
wonderful thank you councillors
um so unless anyone's looking to make
any closing remarks i'm happy for us to
proceed to
the vote on this
if you can just confirm whether or not
you are looking to approve or refuse the
permission
on this application counselor proctor
uh approved char thank you councillor
councillor carey
approved chairman thank you thank you
council councillor rigby
cancel a big b
console i think you might be on mute can
you
can you hear us i'm not sure if your
screen looks a bit frozen
okay we'll move on to uh councillor
morgan
approved chair thank you thank you
councillor councillor thomas
approved chair thank you councillor
councillor
stanley approved chair thank you
thank you councillor welton approved
chair thank you
thank you councillor stennis
counselors done it can can you hear us
oh if you can just repeat that i just
missed the start of your um
decision there
thank you councillor councillor nugwash
approved chair
thank you council the councilor dr
barclay
thank you vice chair i approve the
officer's recommendation to grant
thank you councillor um councillor
new groceries next to me that's have we
have you already voted cancel the new
gosh i think you
jumped places on my screen
i voted i said i agree and
counselor i can know that um i approve
chair
thank you councillor um it looks to me
as though
councillor rigby has um been removed
from the call
can we just clarify are we happy just
accepting the members who have voted
i'm not sure someone from democratic
services can clarify
or perhaps miss cobian i don't i don't
believe
um council welton has voted i have
i i have indeed voted
and sorry ms coburn i just missed your
comments yes sorry you can proceed
without me
um i make it i will also be voting to
approve this application so i make it
that
um this application has been approved by
those members who voted
and we can now proceed onto the next
item
for consideration which is application
one double zero
four five eight forty five salisbury
road
and as i understand it there's no
speaker to this item
the application is listed on page eight
of your report pack and will be
introduced by
mr day yeah thank you
hello
can you hear me i can hear you i i've
not seen any
shared screen though with the
presentation sorry no i don't know
my screen just went blind i'll just try
and share the screen
okay i'm assuming you can see that now
can you nothing's showing
us yet
so
you
john let's have a go steve i know you've
done it have i
no maybe not no i think that's fine it
just
it just said that you were already in it
i think no i'm not in it
i held on
we got that now yeah
right i i can't actually see anything
i've got a spinning circle but um
um
right okay
i'm not being able to click through the
screen
the slideshow is on the screen but i'm
not being able to click through it
that's fine i'll move it as you
as you move through the presentation
steve okay all right i'll just carry on
then um
the application is being reported to
committee because the agent is an
employee of trafford council
the application property is a two-story
semi-detached dwelling house
with a hipped roof an attached garage to
the side and a single story outrigger
located behind that and projecting
beyond the rear elevation
the proposal is for the direction of a
single story rear extension
and a first floor side and rear
extension
the key considerations relate to design
appearance and the residential immunity
impacts upon neighboring properties
no objections are being received the
proposal has been amended to include a
roof design
that would tie in uh more satisfactorily
with the main roof
and the projection of the ground floor
rear extension
has also been reduced to comply with the
sbd4 guidelines
let's consider the proposed extension
alterations would be acceptable in
design terms
and would not have any unacceptable
impacts on the residential community of
neighbouring properties
the development is therefore considered
to be in accordance with policy l7
of the course strategy and guidance in
the mppf
and the application is recommended for
approval
thank you mr day um are there any
members looking to open the discussion
on this item
counselor morgan
yeah um keep my remarks really um brief
um i'm i'm more than happy with this
application
um i think it's very consistent um with
um other developments in the area
um there's been no objections as far as
i'm aware
um and um i think generally the the
style is
is reasonable in keeping with the um the
street scene so i'm i'm happy to propose
um that we uh grant this in line with
office recommendations thank you
thank you councillor uh councillor
proctor indicated
yeah thank you chair uh yeah cal
can carry what council morgan said
really i think it's fairly similar to
the
previous application the applicant has
made some changes which
improved the design and divided out any
any problems with there in the
initial phase um i
don't see any uh unacceptable
overbearing nature or overshadowing
and no impact on immunity so no
really reasons to reject this
application
and as was said doesn't it doesn't seem
to be any representations from other
neighbors
so they presumably are quite happy with
this so happy to approve it as well
thank you thank you councillor are there
any other members
looking to make any observations
no i i mean i i'll just briefly reflect
on the application i think i had a look
on the
uh planning portal at the plans and it
struck me that the
um proposed um
development was of a good standard
and i think it would be a nice
enhancement to the property and
similarly
um to what other members have said when
you look at the street it's quite clear
that there's a precedent for extensions
properties opposite the applicants um
both look at
a couple of them look so that they have
had extensions built on so i don't see
there has been any problem
and the application has been proposed
and seconded
so we will move to a vote unless there's
anyone who wants to make
a closing remark
no um as far as i can tell
uh counselor rigby
still doesn't look to be with us and has
missed most of the discussion
uh anyway so i'll just move through
those numbers you've been here
the whole time so councillor proctor
approving line with officer
recommendations thank you thank you
councillor councillor kirby
approved please chairman thank you
councillor councillor morgan
we please chad thank you counselor
councillor winstanley uh thank you chair
approve
thank you councillor councillor stennit
oh i think you might be on mute
counselor
i'm still not receiving any audio for
you there counselors then if you
are muted
i can hear you now counselor how how
would you like to vote on the
application
thank you councillor stanley council the
new gosh
thank you councillor councillor thomas
approved her thank you councillor
councillor welton
approved chair thank you councillor uh
councillor dr barclay
thank you chairman i uh support the
officer's recommendation to grant
thank you councillor and councillor
akanova
approved chair thank you councillor
canola
uh i will also be voting in line with
officer recommendation to approve the
application
um i think the voting members that was
unanimous and the application
is approved um the next application we
will consider
is one double zero seven six three eth
high school um it's on page 45
of your report pack um and before we
consider it there will be a presentation
from ms
thank you and this application relates
to
blessed thomas hulford's
the site is located on the north side of
it
can you hear me now you keep coming in
and out
breaking up is everybody else getting
the same or is it just mine
no i had the same as well but you seem
to be
better now just towards the end just
before you stop then you seem to be
getting a bit better
okay i'll i'll i'll start again and if
there's any further problems just let me
know
okay the site is located on the north
side of urban road
with residential areas to the east of
altringham
the there's residential properties to
the south and west of the site and an
area of open space to the east
the application seeks planning
permission for the direction of a
three-story building
incorporating 14 classrooms and an
attached sports hall
positioned to the front of the site on
an existing hard surface play area and
part of a car park
the proposals include a replacement hard
play area
formation of new car and cycle parking
spaces
and a bus pickup and turning area two
objections have been received with the
main issues being
additional traffic on urban road and
muslin however there have been no
objections in principle from consultees
the proposal in providing additional
classrooms seeks to
address an existing shortfall and
teaching space at the school
which has resulted in spaces currently
being used
and for teaching which are not
designated classrooms
the classrooms will also provide further
capacity at the school which will help
meet the shortfall in school places in
the alternate area
there is a clear need for the proposed
development and the mppf attaches great
weight into applications which expands
schools to ensure sufficient choice of
school places are available
there's also clear need for the proposed
sports hall given that physical
education is currently
off-site the proposed building is
consumer character of the area
and also the school the um are the
architectural
and features across the across the
existing six form building
are being reflected in the new
development as you can see on the
current cgi's
society and distance retained around the
residential properties ensure
it would not have an adverse impact on
residential amenity
the site is in a sustainable location
and a high proportion of students and
staff
travel by public transport the proposed
development is will provide improved
facilities at the school
and will have an acceptable impact on
the surrounding area
it's therefore recommended that planning
permission is granted
subjections thank you chair
thank you ms lowe's
just got a huge amount of delayed audio
um
are there any members looking to speak
to this application
councilman welton
uh thanks chair um yes i'll be approving
this uh
application it is uh is out of the
different schemes that were proposed i
think it is the the most acceptable
uh old um alternative um
there are a couple of slightly
disappointing aspects to it firstly the
uh
the fact that it says that while it
would be possible to put solar panels
on the sports hall they've decided not
to do it
it doesn't seem to give a reason apart
from the fact that they don't there
there isn't a planning reason for them
to do it which i think is a shame
particularly for a school that has done
a lot over the last few years to improve
its environmental footprint particularly
in terms with the
in terms of litter around the school
perimeter which was awful
a few years ago and i would encourage
them to
reflect on that decision and hopefully
do something about it maybe outside of
the planning process
and the second aspect is that uh
um the the fact that they haven't done a
pedestrian conditions survey as
suggested by tfgm
i mean i think the this is not really a
um
a scheme for adding a 100 or something
pupils this is a scheme for adding 400
pupils because
the the school has been adding you know
it's it's gone beyond its capacity over
several years
and this planning application is really
running to catch up with where the
school has got to
um in terms of people numbers over the
last few years so it would have been
nice
if they had um you know if they'd done
more to reflect on that and
in particular in terms of how
pedestrians access the site
and i noticed from visiting the place to
the the school today
and on previous visits that there is no
drop curb at the um
you know at the main entrance um to the
school and i'm not quite certain how
that can
that can remain i'm sure that's
something that they can work on with the
council
um anyway and i believe it says that
they you know they they will work on
um on that but it would have been nice
to see those kind of that kind of
external access
dealt with within this planning
application
thank you very much thank you councillor
welton
um councillor thomas
thank you chair yeah i will be
supporting the application i think
uh as has been iterated
it is playing catch-up in terms of role
roles
are getting larger and the
upturning the facilities for pupils is
something that we can't
ignore and improve school in increased
improved education i think it's a very
good
and forward-thinking proposal
thank you counselor thomas councillor
morgan
thank you chair um i'm similarly going
to be supporting the application tonight
um
i was really pleased to see um i mean we
we talked about a lot of this committee
um about the um the lack of school
places across the borough
um so um i know councilor wilson said a
lot of this is catch up
but um it's still pleased to see that we
can actually start to fill
to give places that um are otherwise
being taken and
um by school that's over subscribed um
i know there was a couple of objections
um both from residents and st james's
court
um and i do understand some of the
objections i know that
any um school that's near you um issues
with parking from parents dropping their
kids
off or picking them up um but i don't
think
um that any of those issues really are a
planning issue and really should be
dealt with by other committees
and i know there was another issue in
terms of the state of some of the roads
um i know
muscle lane particularly is one that i'm
sure any of us who live in south of the
borough are aware of but again this
isn't something for this committee
um so i'm more than happy with this
development and i'd
be supporting officer recommendations
thank you
thank you councillor morgan and
councillor proctor
yeah i'm also in favor of this this
application pre on lines of what council
morgan was saying really
it's obviously clearly an importantly
needed facility
and it's you know it's going to give a
lot of extra
things for the the school a lot of space
and help the school
move on really um as
we said two letters of objections they
seem to mainly focus on highway issues
which is
often the case in these kind of
applications
but um i've been reassured by you know
what the officers said in terms of the
limited impact that the
proposals would have on on the area
um so i'm i'm reassured by that
and there's one issue about in terms of
the condition of the
the roads in terms of oscillating urban
road but that's not a material
consideration we can take into account
in this committee and hopefully that
will be improved anyway
so happy to approve it as well thank you
chad
thank you councillor did council new
gosh did you indicate
yes yeah thank you um well this is the
least worst of the three options that
were presented
my question isn't please excuse me as
i'm on the reserve and i came
late to this the ecology report um
section 4.12
is rejected um it talks of
well i mean i can't tell what it talks
obviously is my version of it has been
blacked out i hope that's nothing
that uh is important that we should be
considering that is not there for me to
see
[Music]
i'm not sure about some different
planning can just clarify
you know why we might have redacted
parts of the import
because um it would refer to a species
which we would not want to identify
publicly
are you content with that counselor
does it impact on this unidentified
are we is it detrimental to
um if if it were it would say so in the
report
uh i'm happy to take to discuss this
with you
outside the meeting if that would help
councilman newgross you would thank you
very much
nice are there any other members
looking to make a contribution
anyone's indicating anyone now just very
briefly
through my own thinking on this this
application i have to say i think this
was a really comprehensive report and
particularly paragraphs 33 through to 52
on uh in respect to traffic transport
and parking i think you know we can feel
really quite um
content that a lot of thought and
consideration has been invested in
ensuring that
there isn't an adverse impact on
residents and in trying to get
um get a development of this scale right
really
um i was also quite reassured that there
seems to be quite a strong set
of conditions um and as a number of
other members
have um sort of spoken to it looks as
though the applicant's done quite a
lot of work to bring the community along
with them given
um that there are so few representations
against the application i think with the
development at this scale and
particularly
with it being a school you often expect
that there's going to be a huge
number of representations from members
of the public and
that doesn't appear to have been so so i
have no problem
supporting this application this
afternoon i don't think as yet it has
been proposed and seconded
by the numbers though
i'll be happy to chair
oh i'll be happy to second
set up unless there is any member who
hasn't spoken
who's looking to make a contribution
we'll just move
forward to the vote and
counsel the proctor if you can confirm
your vote
in favour in line with officer
recommendations thank you chair
thank you councillor councillor kirby
in favor thank you chairman thank you
councillor councilman morgan
in favour chair thank you councillor
councillor stanley
uh thank you chad in favor thank you
councillor councillor stennett
you can just repeat that counsellor
approve
the recommendation thank you councillor
stanley i'm councillor thomas
approved chat thank you councillor
councillor walton
uh approved chair thank you thank you
councillor
councillor new grosh
approved chair thank you counselor
uh councillor doctor barkley
emin i support the officer's
recommendation to grant
thank you councillor and councillor
akanola
approved chair thank you councillor i
canola
and myself um i shall be voting to
approve the
application in line with office of
recommendations so i make that
um all members all voting members have
approved and the application is approved
unanimously um we can now turn
to application one double zero seven two
three nineteen blueberry road in bowdoin
which is on page 26
of your report pack and there are
speakers to this application
before we hear from them we will receive
an introduction from
ms coley
boyce thank you chairman i'll just
share my screen one second
go can people see that
yep good okay
this application relates to 19 blueberry
road in bowdoin
the application site really comprises a
detached mid 20th century dwelling on a
residential street
uh the site is bound by residential
properties on all sides as you can see
from the location plan
the public right-of-way running along
its side boundary that's the
right of way just there the application
applicant proposes to redevelop the site
to provide
two assemblies that's three bedroom
dwellings the works would also
entail hard and soft landscaping
including front parking areas
the existing site accesses would be
retained with gates added to both
so you can see their flight plan that
that's the outline
proposals the green is the outline of
the existing dwelling on the site
you can see the two parking areas at the
front for each
dwelling and the landscaping at the
front
the dwellings would have front and rear
facing gables
single storey siding rear elements and
front porches
the front porches and single-story rear
elements would have
flat roofs you can see that see that
there and the terrace is above the flat
roof at the rear
the application is reported to committee
because 23 lessons objection have been
received
contrary to the officer recommendation
of approval
if if members refer to their additional
information they'll see that there's an
additional condition proposed
requiring the retention of the privacy
screens on the rear festival
balconies which are here and together
with an amended construction management
plan condition
to reflect additional local highway
authority requirements
repeating issues for consideration
principle of the residential development
together with design and residential
immunity impacts
so there's some more plans here this is
the ground floor plan of both dwellings
first floor plan the loft plan
that that's shown as a storage area
and then the roof plenty because it's
flat roof surrounded by
um by effectively a mansard
so further details have also been
provided an additional
information report regarding the key
dimensions of the proposed development
those dwellings would have a ridge
height of 7.96
um meters with the front gables being
the same height you
see that there in relation to the
dwellings either side
uh in comparison there was a previously
withdrawn application which i'll just
look through to
um this would have had a height of 8.4
meters to the main roof
now the drawings here are slightly to a
different scale so actually that looks
smaller but you can see where the eaves
line is that eaves line
is is should be if the dweller if the
drawings are the same scale at the same
level that each line hasn't changed
so we have to imagine that that that all
pushes up a bit but you can see that the
gables there are are somewhat higher and
there are the two doors there um the
footprint of the dwellings would have
been similar
this previous application was
recommended for for refusal for three
reasons relating to the impact on the
character of the area
in fact on the neighboring property at
number 21 bluebird road from the scale
of the development
overlooking to both the joining parties
from balconies
however officers think that they above
reasons have been overcome in the
current application
this is because the dwellings proposed
in the current scheme would have a lower
ridge height
with gables reduced significantly in
height to the same height as the main
ring
the previously proposed dorm is removed
in addition the currently proposed
scheme would have smaller and lower
front porches
reduction in boundary treatment appears
timber fences
ratings removed the rear ground of first
floor elements of the dwelling adjacent
to 21 degree road
have also been reduced in projection or
pulled away from the boundary to comply
with our guidelines
and privacy screens are now shown on the
balconies condition recommended to
ensure the retention of these
therefore we think this development will
be acceptably designed not
an acceptable impact on residential
immunity there are no highways concerns
the application is therefore recommended
for approval subject to conditions
thank you chairman thank you
miss coley um now i had understood that
there would be two speakers against
application counselor
churchill and um also mr young
as i understand it though i think
councillor churchill has
work commitments until about half five
um is that mr young on the call she does
chairman um but mr pearson will read out
a statement on her behalf
but if you want to take mr young first
that's that's that's up to you
that's fine um mr young girl you have
three minutes
so can you hear me yep make your
representation and if you run over we'll
just um
politely ask you to wrap up fine
mr chairman i'd like to thank you for
the opportunity to address the committee
on this application
to demolish the existing dwelling house
and 19 blueberry road
and replace it with a pair of large
semi-detached houses
i live next door at number 17 and i'm
speaking on behalf of a large number of
local residents
blueberry road was developed around 1960
and has
33 detached properties some of which
have been demolished and rebuilt as
detached houses
and most of which have been extended or
modified
all of these detached houses have
garages along with hard standing for at
least three cars
the road has no semi-detached houses
blueberry road is narrow being only 6.1
meters
wide and significantly narrower than the
surrounding roads
stanhop road for example is over 7.4
metres wide
because of its narrowness visitors who
can't be accommodated on the driveways
of house of the houses tend to park
their
cars partly on the pavement forcing
pedestrians out into the road
in 2019 the house of commons transport
select committee
recommended that paving park pavement
parking be made illegal throughout
england as it has been in london since
1974.
so far 23 letters of objection have been
received from the occupiers of
properties in the area
of which 13 are from residents of
blueberry road
there are many specific objections
firstly the proposed development is
slightly smaller than that one proposed
originally but still has a large
footprint
and would dwarf the surrounding
properties it also takes some five
meters of garden
technically considered to be green field
the development
is proposed to protrude some 3.5 meters
beyond
the line of the back of the neighboring
properties in view of its height it
means that the rear patios and
conservatives of these properties will
be massively overshadowed by the new
development
the proposed semis have no garages and
the plans show
three very small park cars parked
together on the hard standing of each
house
making a total of six cars in practice
residents of the new semis will park
their large cars on the dangerous bend
in the road
as would any visitors
the properties are currently classified
as three-bedroom semis but the loft
space will most likely be developed into
an additional bedroom
thereby thereby exacerbating the parking
requirements
the development is completely out of
character with other detached properties
in the road
and would set a precedent for allowing
similar proposals in the future
in summary we residents see this as a
speculative venture designed to maximize
profitability
at the expense of neighboring properties
and risking highway
safety we realize that the council is
under pressure from the government to
increase the supply of affordable
housing
but all this does is deliver one extra
luxury property
at the expansion of the expense of many
local residents
thank you
thank you mr young um i think mr pearson
are you happy to read out councillor
churchill's statement
yes certainly shannon okay this is a
churchill statement
i'd like to start by thanking the
committee for giving me the opportunity
to speak
in support of the objection to this
planning application
the site at 19 blueberry road in bowdoin
a number of residents have contacted me
to bring to my attention
their objections to this planning
application including residents from the
joining properties directly affected by
the proposals
there are a number of issues with this
plenty application and i would like to
highlight the main objections
are essentially twofold the impact on
the local area
and the impact on residents of
neighbouring properties
blueberry road is a leafy area with
significant space between properties
this is predominantly characterized by
two-story detached residences
large private gardens developed areas of
landscaping
established trees and laundry walls
this provides an important element of
character and spaciousness to the street
the proposal is to demolish the detached
four bedroom dwelling and erect a pair
of three bedroom
semi-detached houses there are no other
semi-detached dwellings on the road
hose structure has a larger footprint
than the existing building
two houses being squeezed onto the site
of one house
to achieve this part of the proposed
development will be on land currently
forming part of the garden
essentially a greenfield site the
development is disproportionate to the
size of the plot
is incongruous to the area and does not
enhance the street scene
the plan to eliminate existing greenery
on the plot with greater hard standing
up front
and limited scope for planting only adds
to the incongruous nature of the
proposed building
street the second main objection is the
impact upon residents
the immediate negative impact of this
development will be on the immunities of
the residents of numbers 17 and 21
in order to maximize the size of the
proposed dwellings
in return the development has two-story
elements which protrude approximately
3.3 meters
into the garden beyond the line of
neighbouring properties
being only two meters from the boundary
of number 17
2.5 meters from the boundary of number
21.
the impact would be overbearing on the
neighboring properties and cut
light to their rear patios and
conservatories
parking for the proposed development is
also an issue for residents
there is a concern that the parking
spaces for such a development are likely
to be insufficient
to propose driveways and parking areas
being relatively small
and difficult to maneuver this is likely
to result in additional street parking
in a relatively narrow street
which could impact on safety especially
since the development is also situated
on abandoned road adjacent to a public
footpath road crossing
and as such represents a hazard for
pedestrians
and traffic through or on the road and
pavement parking
in summary the harm to the character of
and street scene of blueberry road
and the immunity of its residents
outweighs the addition of one extra
dwelling
to the area she would in any case having
negligible effects
meeting the borders housing needs i
asked the committee to protect the
character and residents of blueberry
road
and reject this planning
thank you mr pearson uh we do have a
speaker in favor of the application
is mr hussein on the call
yes you know and you have three minutes
to
make your comments mr hussein if you
went over we'll just quite
ask that you wrap up thank you hello
hello yeah that's great if you go ahead
thank you
thank you for the opportunity for
speaking um i'm the agent on on this
application on and i'm speaking on
behalf of the applicant
um so the proposals for a pair of
semi-designed properties
for a family family houses
one of the houses will be taken by the
applicant um
the the the applicant themselves are a
young growing family
uh they've lived in the area uh for the
last 10 years
and they have they're looking to
continue living in the area and
contributing
to the uh the local community for the
coming years
so it's in their vested interest to uh
to build a high quality building that
they can live in um
and one of the residents alongside them
so
um i think the key point that is that
the
this is not a a property developer who's
looking to make some money and disappear
this is a long-term investment for this
particular applicant
in terms of uh planning policy the in
line with policy l1 and l2 this proposal
contributes to to be the overall housing
targets to provide
family housing within a brownfield site
that is within an established
residential area within
a located in the sustainable area
and whilst providing economical benefit
during construction
uh there are many examples of
semi-detached properties in the area
that have recently been approved and
they've gone through the whole planning
process
and some of them have been built um
to name a few of them thirty-one ibrook
road approved in 2019
nine bulgari road approved in 2019 sixth
and hope
road approved in 2019 land to the rear
of three and four cranes road approved
in 2018
23 stan downhill pro the proven 2017
and and there's many more there's a few
examples
so there's an established present story
of
uh applications of uh
being approved in the last five years or
more
for semi-detached properties in the area
in terms of design and underplanning
process we
originally submitted the planning
application in june 2019
which was drawn in october 2019 we then
started a pre-application
process working closely with the
planning department and team leaders
to establish a design and masking
appropriate for the site
we resubmitted our application in may
2020
with amendments and continue to work
with the planning department
to amend the scheme in keeping with
current policy
and and looking at the immunity of
neighboring properties
having said that there are many
examples of buildings within this
on on on blueberry road and all the
other sites
within the area which are much larger um
a notable example is 20 blueberry room
which
which is located indirectly opposite
outside uh
it was approved in 2014 and his hand was
built
um that currently stands at one meter
above
the ridge height is one meter above our
proposed recharge and keep up just three
minutes miss you saying you just want to
finish
your last point yeah so
so with regards to masking if you
compare 20 blueberry robot and 19
blueberry rod you can see a huge
difference in in size
considering they had bought a dorm of
bungalows on each side when they were
constructed so
there's examples of semicircular
properties and large properties within
the area
that have gone through the planning
process and receive approvals for it
we've worked actively with the planning
department to get us approved
to get this to the point where it is we
would uh appreciate and and
and for our approval today
okay thank you mr hussein um are there
any members
looking to open the discussion for this
application
uh counselor wins stanley
ah thank you chair um it's an
interesting development this one
and it reminds me of um several of these
developments which you've
come before the planning committee
planning committee since i've been on
the committee
and in line with all of them
instinctively you drive up this road
and you think this is lovely why would
you do anything why would you do
anything to change it
and i totally get the concerns of the
residents around over development
perceived incongruity
noise disturbance lack of privacy
increasing traffic parking issues etc
etc etc
but the issue we've got is that the the
plans
fit they are within the current planning
regulations
so all of that said i can find
no planning reason to turn this down
particularly as the
um uh the developer has worked with the
council
to um to get this within the regulations
um and when you activate the tilt of
balance i can
i can find no reason to turn it down i
would love to be able to find a reason
but i can't
so i will be reluctantly voting in favor
of officer's recommendation to grant
thank you chair thank you councilman
stanley councillor dr barkley
uh thank you chairman um blueberry road
does have a lovely expansive feel
and definitely as you go down it is very
open
and um very spacious feeling to it and i
do feel that
squeezing uh two semi-detached
properties onto the site will have
a detrimental impact on the character of
the street
on the street scene and i do actually
feel given that the footprint of the two
new houses is actually larger than the
original house but they will lead to a
feeling of closing in of that part of
the road and the sense of over
development
and so therefore i do feel that um there
are
reasons for us to refuse the application
and i i won't be supporting it thank you
chairman
thank you councillor dr barclay and
councillor morgan
thank you chair um i'm kind of i
have similar sentiments to what
councilwind stanley said i'm councillor
barkley but probably come to a different
conclusion than councillor
dr barclay um i have to be honest i
don't particularly
like the plans um i mean i i've actually
got a in front of me the
the plans and the the the shape of the
properties
of the property including the gardens
and grounds as well as the house
themselves
look odd i mean the gardens look weirdly
long
um and um i do think
that there's just something about shape
that kind of makes you
in human nature to look at it but i
don't see a reason to object to it
i went down last week um this road
and um there is a there is a
a um character to the to the area
but i don't think unlike some of the
previous applications that have come
from to the committee that it is
very in keeping we've got just around
the corner there is a absolutely huge
house that's been developed very
recently just over the road there's
several large houses
and there's not a consistent there's a
there's a certain age of
a lot of the properties but it isn't as
consistent as some of the others that
have come in front of us
um there's a lot of objections that come
forward i've i have read through
at least the majority of them and
there's a few that i think
probably i i'm probably worth
emphasizing more than others
um so i think it does go a lot further
back
these two properties than the current
one does and certainly think for
number 17 and number 21 i can see
the worries they've got um but again i
don't think it
it it changes the situation
um and then the thing that i really
don't i and this has come before is with
big properties before
is the is the empty empty space on the
second floor
and i really do understand the concerns
about that um but on a planning basis we
can't object to that so
um i will listen to the rest of the
debate um
to what other speakers say but at the
moment i'm reluctant
i'm going to come in line with officer
recommendations thank you jeff
thank you councillor morgan and
councillor welton
thank you chair um what i
really object to in these kind of
developments is is the presumption
towards uh
towards balconies i think it's perfectly
reasonable to
to you know to build two houses on this
property but
but i i don't understand why a house you
know a family house like this has to
have balconies on the first floor when
you've got a
very nice garden uh there there won't be
a planning reason apart from
now particularly now they've got screens
why why we can't let this go ahead um
but i hope that one day that you know
we'll
with developments of this kind we'll
have we'll be able to put in a
presumption against balconies and
the you know the the overlooking that
this this causes
neighbors and i think if if this um
this proposal didn't have any balconies
in it i think it may well have
met with a much more favorable uh
reception from the
from the neighbours so i think the
architects have maybe shot themselves in
the foot by proposing them in the first
place um
there are a couple of uh aspects of the
objections that uh that i dis
disagree with um firstly i was there at
seven o'clock this morning when the max
you'd think the maximum amount of
parking would
would be there there was one car parked
right away over the pavement completely
unnecessarily because the
road is actually by you know a lot of
trafford standards is actually quite
wide
if you've only got parking on one side
there's plenty of space
um for a car to park on the road and
another car to park by and as i say
there was only one car there
um the other thing is that uh that a lot
of the houses on the street
have absolutely maximized their um you
know their width across the plot the new
builds
um they're very you know they're
squeezed up against their borders even
though they're on absolutely massive
plots
um and therefore i don't think this you
know although this is a slightly smaller
plot i don't think this represents as a
a break from
from the the structures that have been
going up on up the last
few years um and given that there's no
planning reason for
you know um to to um not to uh
for this to go through i think i will be
supporting you
thank you councillor welton um i can't
see any other members
having indicated that they'd like to
speak so i will just use this
opportunity to
um clarify my own thinking about the
application i have to say i think
you know i've been on the plumbing
committee for some nearly two years now
i think it is
uh two and a half and this i think is
probably one of the more difficult
applications or at least
a more difficult residential application
that i've seen for before
the committee i really welcome what
other members have already said and i
found myself in agreement with a number
of
remarks you know council walter and i
agree with you that you know i don't
have any concern
um about the parking or about the impact
of upon traffic on the street i disagree
with you about balconies i think they
can be quite a nice feature
and but you know councillor morgan i
think you really succinctly
um summed up my own thinking really
um i think it's entirely reasonable for
residents to be
concerned about the application this is
a really nice part
of the bulba and when you go down blue
view road there hasn't been a huge
amount of change and i can understand
why residents and neighbors want to
protect the character
of the street one of the things that i
did when um
i saw this application was before this
this evening
was to look at the previous refused
application because i agreed with the
decision
um that was made by committee at that
point particularly
in uh respective sort of massing and
height and scale
of the development and i think what's
not clear
from the plans that have been provided
is quite how much of a reduction
there has been between the old
application that was refused and the
application that's before this
this afternoon so i'm really grateful
that officers have clarified that
and provided the detail for that in the
additional information report
and also in the introduction that we
received um
earlier um i think that you know the
report's quite honest really because it
acknowledges in paragraphs 20 to 24 and
also
in paragraphs 30 to 35 that this
application would be an intensification
of the plot as it currently is you know
and that's clear
when you see the footprint of the
current unit and then
what's being proposed but i think really
you know what comes through for me
is that it might not be to everybody's
liking but the application before this
is policy complaints and i think a
number of members have sort of testified
to that when they said that you know
despite their
um best intentions and scrambling around
to find a reason they cannot find a
planning grounds
for refusing the application so i think
really i said before that
you know council morgan sums up my
thinking i think reluctantly i find
myself in a position where
i i would be approving the application
this evening
um i don't know if there are any other
members looking to speak
and i'm conscious that as yet the
application has not been well
a decision has not been proposed and
seconded on the application
and so if there is anybody who can just
be if you want to indicate
nope i'm not receiving any takers there
uh counselor thomas you
put your hand up thank you chair
the the facades down the on the on the
individual houses down the road differ
vary and
again without reiterating or rehashing
everything that's been said
uh whilst i do understand
why uh neighbors and residents on the
street would have
concerns the the squeezing in
aspect is elongating it and there's no
difference from
what we were shown before between the
two properties on either side uh 19 uh
sorry 17
21 there is still that gap so
in light of need to move something i
propose reluctantly to
accept thank you councillor thomas is
there any member
i'd be too second into the application
i'm happy to do that chairman councillor
carey thank you councillor curry
um the application has now been um
proposed and seconded for approval
unconscious not every member has spoken
if is there any
member who would like to speak make any
final comments regarding the application
nope okay well we'll move to a vote then
as it has been proposed and seconded
for approval um councillor procter if
you can confirm your vote please
uh with some reluctance chair uh support
officer recommendation to approve
thank you councillor councilman morgan
sport officer recommendation to approve
chair
thank you councillor councillor win
stanley
uh with some reluctance uh uh vote for
officers recommendations grant
thank you councillor councillor stannit
recommendation thank you councillor
councillor negros
yeah i think reluctantly i will go
support the officer recommendation on
this one
thank you councillor councillor carey
i vote to grant the application chairman
thank you thank you councillor uh
councillor rigby
jones i was unable to reconnect until
halfway through the debates or else
thank you councillor uh councillor
thomas
thank you jeff yep uh grant please
thank you councillor councillor welton
i'll also vote to grant chair thank you
thank you councillor uh councillor dr
barkley
chairman i don't support the officer's
recommendation to grant
thank you councillor and the council of
canola
votes grant the application thank you
councillor
and myself i will vote to approve the
application in line with officer
recommendation
so make that one vote to refuse and two
or ten votes to approve so the
application is
granted um now that is
all of the applications for
consideration on the agenda tonight
um i think miss coley indicated that she
wanted
um members just have a quick chat at the
end of the meeting but
we just make sure that we um
stop the live